guys whether it's Pro play or soloqueue
powerful abilities are essential to any
character's success now before we get
into how we actually rank this list of
the top ten abilities let's get a couple
things straight first of all no
Ultimates we already did an entire video
just for them second of all no items and
no passives either oh and if you want
the ability to swag out your wardrobe
how do you do fellow kids let's well
check out the score eSports online merch
Department where we got some pretty sick
t-shirts like this one now I'm done
selling out let's get on with the list
from the strongest to the meta defining
to the iconic here are the top 10
abilities kicking off our list is
invoker sunstrike from dota 2 now sure
we could have put his invoke ability on
this list but honestly it felt like
cheating so we decided to highlight his
global nuke
sunstrike is a straightforward flashy
and powerful skill shot that is
responsible for some of DotA's hypest
kills strike you don't throw it could be
aimed anywhere on the map with or
without vision and serves as a constant
threat for retreating enemies through
the short cast on before it lands sun
strike is one of the harder skill shots
to hit in dota but oh boy when it does
it brings the crowd to their feet
[Applause]
so try
[Music]
we bet you were expecting HUDs road hog
or Blitzcrank here but with so many grab
and pull abilities it was really hard to
just pick one that said Thresh's hook
has a unique property that sets it apart
which is why it comes in at number 9 on
our list
with the option to travel to the hook
target thresh has the most versatile
hook ability in league of legends could
be chilling smite and lira decides okay
that's fine we're just gonna go and now
both TSM bottom later could be in some
trouble in terms of league of legends
it's got a pretty long range short cast
time and serves as a long enough disable
to basically guarantee death when
combined with the rest of thrush's kit s
that's why it's called a death sentence
number eight on our list goes to the
skill that everybody loves to hate
that's right it's Yasuo wind wall with
the ability to negate all projectiles
including certain Ultimates wind wall
makes Yasuo one of the most flexible
melee characters in League of Legends it
allows him to bully ranged carries in
Lane and single-handedly disrupts
teamfights thanks to the width and
nearly instantaneous cast time coming in
at the number 7 spot is nature's
prophets teleportation which is well
exactly what it sounds like it allows
the user to teleport anywhere on the map
without requiring vision and what you
choose to do with such power is entirely
up to you
they were a little bit too afraid to go
for anything but phone seven he's gonna
try to sleep the car oh these are the
next level stretch Oh teleportation
gives nature's prophet of global
presence throughout the game making him
one of the scariest heroes to play
against as just his existence alone
applies pressure to the entire map do
anything to overly aggressive that was
without black hole that was without the
chronosphere to an oboe d7 he was
farming up the ancients and now
admirable Baggins found him back tracks
galore but it still bugs so they're
gonna fall inside oh and don't even
think about leaving your own base in
League of Legends tahm Kench is one of
the hardest champions to kill and is
able to survive in situations almost no
other champion could and thanks to
devour he can lend that survivability to
an ally putting this ability at number 6
on our list there's the cold of day
looking for a good double knockout comes
out from Tom but the nature's cross is
the FA Cup right in the backline the
exhaust comes in and tal grabs the
buzzkill
not only can devour save allies from
certain death but tahm Kench can use it
offensively as well to swallow an enemy
rendering them useless in a fight only
to be spat back out into the clutches of
his team dragon players are being lost
and since he could turn back time but
turtle says no way simply put a good
tahm Kench can change the entire flow of
the game with expert use of devourer
bris divide his dogs five-acre he has
his onions as well doing so much damage
but Katie okay living shadow is one of
the most iconic non ultimate abilities
in all of League of Legends which is one
of the reasons it lands in at number
five on our list have a choice about the
positioning and another kill when he
doesn't have a choice about it
Zed's w allows him to safely harass in
lane thanks to the shadow mimicking his
other abilities and with the added
option to swap places with his shadow it
offers all the traditional utility of a
flash TSM is running for the hills
winter five should definitely be using a
bit of this to get a push on as well if
TS is up it's on we headed the solar
flare I just thought they'd have to keep
vision of something they already got
[Applause]
Pearson running for his life just
another pencil this is gotta be combined
with the rest of Zed's Arsenal living
shadow enables him to dive a target
while staying deceptively safe unlocking
much of Zed's terrifying outplay
potential coming in at number four is
the fireball that redefined the entire
fighting game genre the Hadouken was the
first projectile to appear in a fighting
game and marked the first time in which
a character could control space away
from their body
every Street Fighter game is balanced
around the fireball allowing for styles
of play that otherwise wouldn't exist
the Hadouken inspired ranged abilities
and other fighting games and has become
a staple of the genre
and perhaps the only thing more iconic
and street fighter than ryu himself is
his Hadouken previously seen in the form
of an ultimate and now turned into a
basic ability our number three spot goes
to Mercy's resurrect while its
modern-day form is not quite as powerful
as its original rendition reviving a
single ally is more than enough to
change the course of a fight as a basic
ability Mercy's resurrect is now far
more impactful throughout the game than
its previous iteration which required an
ultimate charge and despite having the
longest cooldown of any basic ability in
the game it is often more than enough to
win a battle
somehow he nodded off on the sato I do
not even know I didn't get knocked off
that one Fisher may have been the most
impactful basic ability of the past two
internationals and perhaps throughout
the history of dota 2 which is why it's
the runner-up on our list but he tosses
one over and then he's gonna live he's
so in the photosphere he drops him on
three funny episodes there in the
periphery of the chrono it has an AoE
stun persist to block movement and can
be thrown out from a safe distance
hitting a fissure can set up other
harder to hit skills and basically
spells death for any unsuspecting foe
more often than not you won't see it
coming and even if you do it's not so
easy to dodge
the hands of a skilled player Fischer is
one of the strongest initiation tools in
all of dota 2 oh my god it blocks off
three they're all gonna die plink
instead as well they don't even get the
misses they don't even get his birds Oh
No
taking the crown on our list is the most
important ability in any MOBA blink a
skill that lets you instantly teleport a
short distance while simple in nature
the versatility that it offers is
undeniable and single-handedly changes
the way a game can be played enabling
high mechanic offensive and defensive
plays charges which may just be enough
of miracle predicts the bars right got
plates in from him thank you
yep Sora big walk back and it's not just
limited to MOBAs either characters like
dhalsim from Street Fighter and tracer
from overwatch also share the mechanic
the most iconic iterations belong to
anti-mage and queen of pain who can
access bling from level 1 without
purchasing an item giving them pressure
and safety in the early phases of the
game he's so damn slow shackle not gonna
let blinking from yell maybe it with the
ultimate babe Bernie Bernie actually
living still alive Barry oh please use
and blink never falls off as it can be
used to accelerate farm finish off
enemies and escape from danger all
throughout the match outside of dota
blink is one of the most important
mechanics in any competitive video game
and is the most powerful basic ability
there is plain and simple point beat
cocoa
hero play but can't they get it through
to the rest of point beam well guys
that's all we got for you on top 10 this
week now why is the watching don't buy a
shirt or something
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button
[Music]